hello look do you wanna come tastefully
Thank You lon Danielle Joe dan hello
hopefully you've watched the Alita
honest trailer by now and if you watch
this you get you know more of a
free-form discussion of what we were
thinking some jokes that didn't make the
final cut
and maybe a clue to next week's honest
trailer some of your questions is all
grab bag of stuff yeah I get through a
bunch whole bunch um first Aleta mixed
feelings about this film I don't think
it was bad I don't think it was great I
think it was an entertaining if somewhat
dated film that kind of let you realize
it was written in the 80s and been in
development since the 90s yeah it's a
they're just uh and a lot of motor ball
for a movie about Android for Mars and a
war oh there we did a little bit of like
a light wiki dive into this there's
Howard by fandom
there's this thing called space karate
that figures pretty prominently which
pans are kunst I believe is a derivative
of that tracks there's a robot that
wanted to create a karate planet rich
vein of maybe space karate based stuff
that the the movie could have drawn but
I assume that was in you know part three
of the plan I am going to go read that
immediately yeah I don't know why you
don't look we've proven that we don't
need origin stories anymore people are
pretty smart
yeah like Peter Parker we don't need to
know some questions yeah but like we've
had a bunch of Aleta's we can
she's a smart murder lady that's also a
robot in a cyberpunk we've seen it like
just just get to the karate planet just
start with karate plan and just be like
a million while back there was a smart
robot girl and they they've rebuilt her
out of a dumpster and I'll go okay yeah
yeah and I'm there it definitely has the
feeling of one of those adaptations that
if you're not familiar with the source
material you could feel them feeling
pressured to throw more stuff in like
well leave we got it we got to adapt
motor ball we got to put this in here
we're gonna put this guy in here I've
got to talk about his sword and it's
like at a certain point if you're just
watching it as a movie and not expecting
to get all these you know dots crossed
or whatever that's not the expression
but you don't need all that stuff yeah
I'm glad you guys are having fun I've
already been through this once with
Aleta cuz I've reviewed it so I've been
on this merry-go-round one time and have
fun because I did not because it's the
best movie I did not review it favor
favorably when it came out I will say I
came in kind of hot it was one of those
things where we saw the movie and then
the the embargo was dropping so we just
went right into the review and I came in
a little hot I was a little angry at it
maybe a little too angry but I stand by
what I said I was I was I was a little
upset because this movie is all set up
it's all stamp and and I was a bit hot
under the collar cuz I'm like I know
James Cameron and I know Robert
Rodriguez and I know they know how to
tell a story and and I did not like this
movie was pretty much all set up for the
later movies and people's like whoa did
I guess you didn't like Lord of the
Rings either and it's like no if you
look at Lord of the Rings structurally
each movie has a structure they have
character arcs they have storylines
throughout the film that are introduced
and resolved in the shot together so
it's like that's one story well lead is
an ongoing story because nobody
oh there's a years and years of a manga
to adapt right I'm just saying why this
is my divide me drawing it's just like I
think that this movie and loadings are
completely different because Loring's
actually was able to make movies that
didn't just feel like setup for the next
movie in and of themselves they had
story lines and the major conflicts in
each of those ones outside of the super
conflict of destroying the Ring was
resolved whereas this movie I felt was
and introduced the characters and the
world and that was about it it was like
introducing and then we're setting up
for the sequel and so yeah Connolly gets
put inside a briefcase I thought this
movie didn't it cuz it's not all
negative I think I just said at the top
that I liked it it sort of but it looks
incredible this yeah looks awesome and I
know that like awesome robot fighting
does not a movie make but there was some
awesome robot fighting in this and I
thought that they did a good job of kind
of I won't say westernizing but making
more believable the anime aesthetic like
the eyes did not bug me as much as I
thought they would when those bug eyes
first came yeah yeah yeah you know if
the nicest thing I can say about this
movie is that the giant eyes didn't
bother me then the giant eyes didn't
bother me I I'm torn on this because
yeah the robot fighting look cool but
also like a really good game of
overwatch could be fun to watch too and
the graphics are so I'm sort of torn
there it's like is that good enough for
me to come out and be like you know what
I liked this movie or can I just watch
like a let's play of zero dawn horizon
or fortnight thank you I misplaced a
word I don't know man I don't know
enough yeah because otherwise there
wasn't a whole lot going on I got a mess
I found it pretty entertaining I enjoyed
the movie I think that's why
overburdening it was so much setup an
exposition bugged me because when it
wasn't doing that I was like all right I
could I could watch a hunter-warrior
take on but
robots in a bar that's that sounds fun
yeah robot fighting can be enough for me
sometimes yeah when they hunt a hunter
killers killer is a separate movie there
hunter warriors right yeah back me up on
this robot jocks in this movie oh we're
only player 1 of cyberpunk animation I
feel like there's a few movies that are
on the timeline like that's our future
before we get to a lead a future and I
feel like robot jocks is one of y'all
but like we'll be in robot jocks time
and then plenty of time to talk robot
jocks as we watched the NHANES trailer
for that's an angel anytime they
transition its arena comes Hollywood's
best adaptation of a manga yeah yeah
which to be fair is a really low bar to
clear that's from our honest trailer for
Dragonball Evolution yeah yes we added
the fart noise but wait hang on the
audience wasn't adding that fart noise
in their mind as well also we had about
a maybe six times as long fart montage
and aside to cut down to just one choice
fart I was still editing them when you
guys really put the farts and I was like
and and people liked it I'm continued
I'll put this in my art I did a little
bit when when I first saw the script and
you had Dragonball Evolution in there I
was like there are more recent examples
of this thing that we're talking about
but I didn't realize them anymore I
didn't realize they were the farts yeah
I saw some people sticking up for ghosts
in the show it's fine actually I feel
about the same as ghosts in the shells
they do this movie was just like both
great visuals wrapped around the most
unimaginative scripts and it's not I
know that there's stories familiar
because lots of other stories were based
on this story but like there's really
great movies also that are based on
familiar stories that have great scripts
to me in my opinion have great scripts
and are able to innovatively and
interestingly tell the story and then
there are movies like I thought this and
ghost in the shell' that were just like
coasting on the
visuals and then the most cliched read
it seen it all before screenplays in the
world and that's sort of I don't always
enough I'm thinking more in the middle
on that like maybe it's cuz I've seen
the ghost in the shell' anime and I've
never seen the original Lolita but I
think everything you just said is true
of the new ghost in the shell' they're
just it's just like let's make it look
like the cartoon but it's live action
people will be blown away and it's got
your Hansons there but this one I think
it is doing more to sort of break up the
story and think rethink it not a total
success but we'll never agree I wants
glass eight times like Oleta battle
angel
meet Aleta a cyborg with the eyes of a
doll the softness of a body pillow and
the heart of a MacGuffin you have a
heart strong enough to power all of
iron's city for years on the surface
she's the internet's perfect woman
a sexy killer dumpster baby who's
totally legal some 300 years old and
will kiss you if you give her chocolate
so sir we should talk about our favorite
scene to reference and reenact with each
other where waltz makes it very clear
that when Aleta gets a new body one
that's more post-pubescent than the
basement he makes it very clear that
this was her own decision conscious she
found a body in a spaceship that she
wants to install on her brain in and the
body reacts to her mind it makes her
look the way she visualizes myself and
he goes oh look it's it's very important
that I point out that it's idea that's
how she sees herself not how I would be
designed if I gave her breast but she's
doing that to herself so it's cool
it was completely her decision unlike
the decision to dress her in the clothes
of my daughter and also named her after
my doctor
totally normal things on Lin's this is
not anyone else's sensual bodies or man
would be very self before me itself not
me the body certainly not original
directive in a medicines by men in any
way be completely to the lady Robert
Rodriguez was very against all from this
robot yeah we watched that scene if they
haven't seen Alito we all got a kick out
of that as she matures via her own
subconscious I wanted he's calling it
out and maybe it was the right decision
to ignore me here I wanted the whole
honest trailer to be back you know maybe
that's that's not how we do it's very
good reason because it's so much else to
talk about but we really that's all we
really want to talk about is that and
this shows what are the great that's a
way to like front peg prank our audience
to do that and then do starring and let
them think we're gonna go back to making
a real honest I went to medical schools
in solemn they did never taught me this
procedure this is not in my wheelhouse
it's not my expertise is alien
technology and the helpless to visit
[Music]
she's older than you think you guys 300
he's got a hit mission that scene right
there dogs blood
pinkeye doc she loved she's not just
some random dog yeah I asked she petted
it once yeah she loved that she loved
that dog it was nice which is at the
beginning of every screenwriting manual
you know I was shocked when they killed
the dog you know in this movie and then
I was even more shocked she's like John
wicken that way yeah yeah he doesn't
ever event by the death yester now I
want to see the cut of John Wickery dips
his fingers I just want the scene where
royal Tenenbaum brings her back to the
doctor's house like that's dog's blood
cram a whole franchise worth of
exposition into one short movie
what's final champion does anyone ever
go to zalem what's outside the city what
holds it up why are there so many
languages whose body is this Who am I
who has the power to do that
what happened what hey what are those
things what is that we don't have time
for this when I say that I don't like
the script for the movie this is what
I'm talking about that is it's literally
the cheapest and laziest way to get
exposition into a movie is to have a
character who just asks like what does
that mean well you see 300 years ago
it's never do okay
hey what does this oh well that just the
thing is like okay hey what's that oh
you see when these guys over here okay
hey where does this go it's like oh my
god like that's what I mean it's like
you you that's there's a you can
whatever and and I'm not gonna go over
this again I've already been like as I
mentioned I've been through the wringer
once with this movie when it came out
and I'm gonna do it again but that's
what I mean when I'd say I don't like
the screen yeah I'm like even even
movies that are very heavily X
positioned they try usually they try to
come up with an excuse you trying to
hide it somewhere even if it seemed like
like Doc asking Marty to come down and
shoot a video of his experiment and back
to the future that's the excuse for like
I'm gonna tell the audience about the
time-travel degree but they cleverly
bury it and he needs Marty to film him
so this they don't even try to the point
that
I actually think there was a conscious
decision like let's not even try it
right you have to subway hike you have
to lay the pipe I know it sounds dirty
but it's not technology people try
usually to hide that somehow but this
movie makes no attempt whatsoever to to
disguise and you honestly don't need to
explain as much as they do like you can
get it from context clues like oh the
rich people live in the flying discs and
they put their junk yeah necessarily a
knock on the source which you're like a
lot of these other projects were
inspired by a leader yes but it's still
like you need to be a little more clever
and judicious and how you explain
everything
yes like motor balls no we don't really
it's very simple we don't need it well I
have more questions about motor vuelven
best of the film you don't need to know
the rule it's like it is it a race or is
it a game so they're racing and one
person has the balls who is a whoever
but they they dunk it
exactly okay look when they play the
scrimmage early on which is not in the
stadium then it looks very much like
rugby like it you've got to try to get
the thing in here but people cannot keep
trying to save all your skatepark in
1994 but then the version that they play
in the stadium and I can't tell it's
because like they're not really playing
it because they're all just trying to
kill her so maybe that's why we're
seeing a well the game doesn't matter
because she literally jumps out of it to
go do some yeah it's like you guys paid
to beat yeah took the game away from me
if I was like 10 years ago if I went to
see the Lakers and Kobe Bryant out of
the know I paid to see Kobe Bryant where
are you going what to save his
girlfriend from a robot though I don't
know that yeah it was a Quidditch the
other worst spectator sport in a film is
wondering if you were gonna time movies
that can't movies can't make up sports
it never goes well it explains
everything
prepare for a film said in the 2500 s
made with the best technology of the
2010s that still plays out like it never
left the 90s where everyone is really
into X Games as scene after scene of
motor ball dominates the runtime but
always feels like a skippable minigame
in the Final Fantasy nothing says
cutting edge world like a real place the
boys I need ease this music more yeah
could be the Cure later yeah this is
great I like you guys brought this up
when we were writing this like it's very
90s and I because I was simmered in 90s
movies for 10 years that was my
upbringing I like don't even notice when
stuff is super nice it just feels like
like I when I see you pointed out I'm
like oh yeah there were a lot of like
cheesy rollerblading with your boys
dodging like just doesn't that just
that's just a movie because Daniel this
was sort of the 90 step for sort of your
baby you were the one who was like oh I
hate him yeah this isn't really you
sense the geneco's of it all yeah well
it's early 2000s yeah cuz if you know I
think the first clue other than the
motor ball was I was like oh this was
back this was made when you could still
kill the black person first and no one
would notice or care and that was the
first thing that I noticed I was like oh
huh and that's when I looked back and
realized that yeah it's based on like an
older thing and it's been a script
that's been around forever based on
those that have been around forever
because now people would go out of their
way not to do that just so that people
like me or other commenters they're like
I don't want to even bother and was
never my intention but I'm gonna make
sure that that doesn't happen because
that was such an overused trope and so
when you see something like that that's
been like to the point where they're
trying to make sure it doesn't happen it
kind of stands out yeah well we'll see
in the deleted scenes more 90s things
mm-hmm yeah use the ground Andy's death
keep watchin
Blais and blades to be there are
actually some great human actors in this
movie or at least Miller disembodied
faces promise and every Connelly spends
the film for vaguely helpful Maher
Sheila Ali spends it as a literal
mouthpiece for someone else so we
finally meet Anita
Nova and Christoph Waltz does some heavy
lifting by making the phrase Prancer
Kunz sound cool the instinctive fighting
technique you use is sponsor Const and
some literal heavy lifting by convincing
the audience he could control a giant
rocket-powered hammer
I love his rocket hammer too and just a
moment of silence or not silence motives
speaking how much that doesn't make
sense and yet awesome because man in the
original the first generation of
live-action anime adaptations they'd
have changed that yes maybe like it
looks dumb in live-action there's no way
this old Megan lift it but now they're
so afraid of upsetting the fans yeah
there's like leave it in that is
probably the most final fantasy thing
that's in this is that it's just like
the huge hammer yeah I definitely want
someone running out with a Buster Sword
yeah huge Cloud Strife like size of
eight different people but it's also the
combination of acclaimed Academy Award
winning actor this very if he weren't an
actor he could easily be like a
biologist so very pharmacist
mild-mannered looking bull aged European
man like Vin Diesel sized Dwayne the
rock Hobbs style the Undertaker
yeah
you're the only one who didn't
[Laughter]
underwater with a cigar so yes he could
control a giant rocket-powered hammer so
gear up for the passion project that was
supposed to be James Cameron's opus
till he dumped 600 pages of notes of
Robert Rodriguez and went off to make
avatar sequels instead pause the final
what's that like the day James Cameron's
like I want you to work on something
that I really love and you're like cool
and then he's like
[Music]
I've died that's got to be a mixed bag
of feelings where you're like James
Cameron like that that's like me being
knighted James Cameron's like I believe
in you for this project also I don't
know figure all this crap yeah and a lot
of ways it is the ultimate like the the
greatest effects filmmaker of all time
is putting his faith in you to realize
his vision like what an honor
like with Spielberg when it was Kubrick
and AI you know it's like in on one hand
what's very timid a ting and it's like
wow yeah cool yeah thank you but I think
that like this was so this was 100%
James Cameron's decision we're sure that
he wasn't like he was busy because it
seems like it's getting a page 600 in
the studio my leg we talked about this
Spencer yeah James Cameron between 1997
when he made Titanic in 2009 when he
made avatar and the 10 year sense has
been very busy not making any other
movies yeah documentary cific ocean you
got answer I don't know like what you
twenty years when you're making one
movie a decade I don't know where you
find the time let's do another movie
it's waiting from the tech to catch up
to his that's true yeah well that's my
understanding
I was funny I know that he like he made
avatar to perfect the technology to make
this so thank you good job sieve it like
for years and years I was reading about
he really wants to make this movie but
the text not right now said what's not
ready and then you see and you're like
oh yeah
like you could take an actor space and
like stick it on this is like the first
movie nerd news I ever remember knowing
about though like on whatever AOL group
like dot AOL slash chat yeah we talked
about this this is no less generic or
more generic than avatar I think as far
as like story and scripts oh yeah there
is an alternate universe out there some
split timeline where James Cameron did
not get distracted to do avatar where a
leader battling so might have just been
the movie that Avengers in game
grossing movie of all time okay if this
came out in 3d ten years ago I think it
would've been there'd be a motor ball
spectacle at Disney preparing for Aleta
two through five right now there'd be on
some space station reporting back from
Aleta for you could go to iron town's
edge you can build your own rocket
hammer yeah what a world we would all
the college campuses would have pens -
kunst clubs yeah James Cameron drops 600
pages of notes about people that have
sinned even intense you just did one of
those diving bell suits and there's like
a - it's like sitting at his conference
table see oh man none of those old brass
horns yeah I think it looks great
James is calling it from a shark cage
yes yeah oh man what a treasure
let's keep watch dad with a final
product that blends awesome robot
fighting decades-old cyberpunk tropes
and suddenly ending on a shot of Ed
Norton instead of bringing the story to
a conclusion starring wait we're gonna
do that - oh that's frustrating buzz
struck now we had a debate internally I
think mostly just Lana and I whether and
Norton deserves such yes large reveal I
say yes I think he's an iconic actor of
his generation there there's such a
setup that they really tease it out like
we're gonna make some huge reveal of who
Nova really is and I was like Bradley
well I I didn't hear about who this kind
of gonna be and I was bracing for like a
Jack Nicholson Eastwood like an iconic
if woody harrelson gets it in venom I
use that as my standard but it's just I
don't know there's something inherently
funny about that shot to me that they're
building up somebody takes those tiny
glasses out it's Ed Norton with a goatee
back to Ed Norton can I please see a
little mark right here on his chin it
could just be a shadow but I thought so
[Music]
it's definitely not a goatee okay there
is like the weird cyberpunk skullet yeah
yeah yeah he's got a zorg haircut kind
of also I didn't it took me a second to
realize it was Edward Norton I thought
it was Cameron I'll bring her okay yeah
tiny glasses too which in my in my head
Canon he hates Aleta because he has tiny
eyes it's like the old superhero is the
opposite yes that's a more direct simple
confrontation than the movie has yeah
I'm not quite sure I mean I'm sure the
the manga explains it but like
Murderball it's not possible is the is
the is like the entire economy of the
ground level this is like sending people
up to one person a year this is easing
goes yeah but it's very unclear like yes
apparently motor ball is also like the
government of Iron City because the same
guy marshal alley runs motor ball and is
also handles like the slumlord basically
like the governor or whatever but it's
never they don't like put a point on
that there's no sure they that sure the
points been put on it elsewhere I guess
it's not in the mood you want more
points put on things two-thirds of the
way through movie that's an important
one like you could leave a lot of this
other stuff up in like motor ball is
owned by Nova whatever would be a big
one well this kind of the major arc of
this movie is her becoming final
champion and all this other stuff
happening so I guess it could have been
but she doesn't I'm gonna do it for ya
and like they'll have to enforce the
rules and let her come up to zalem I
guess I thought they were building up to
that was gonna be another like fake out
like yeah we don't really send the
message if it is on but I don't know the
difference between that and the matrix
and I will tell you is because he's like
well the matrix ends the exact same way
with neo saying he's going to come get
us like yes but even though neo says at
the end that he's going to go and get
the machines or that they're fighting
back outside of that it is a complete
story sensible character completes his
evolution from the beginning to the end
of the movie whereas it is a partial
completion of the story in this film I
don't think this film tells the complete
slow if she never finds out who she is
dangling waking up realizing he was in
the matrix and then coming into his own
is the one and that happens before the
matrix I think this is very superficial
comparison that people used to do in the
movie whereas from a storytelling
standpoint I think that I could defend
the matrix much more than this film on
that she does kind of say where she came
from she's a robot from Mars who fights
things I think that's all that we get
the movie intentionally leaves so much
of it vague yeah and not in a way of
just like oh you fill in the blanks but
in a way of just like we're gonna tell
you about this in part 2 we're gonna
research very concrete in this point
you're gonna do you know we're gonna
wrap up this character you know like
there's so many characters that just
don't really just exit the movie and
don't have a they don't finish because
it's like well whatever they're gonna be
in the next one like that's what bothers
me is like now you can still make a part
one that's that that services all of
your characters and leaves them in a
place that makes you feel like they
completed something in this movie and
you could still make a sequel you know
yeah that's crying gonna get his face
back come on we can even know he has an
annoying goatee in this movie I really
rip that like a metal goatee hanging
that's a soul patch it's not a good
tea is a whole different thing come on
guys thank you God arranged irobot dog
hammertime
he's just a skater boy panting him for a
dream
droid randomest crime hidden figure
Smithers
release the saws the first room absorb
if you do not talk about solemn to a
story you know it's too bad this was the
anime James Cameron got obsessed with I
mean it's not bad but why couldn't
somebody have slipped him JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure now we can discuss this I'm
not sure if it's in the deleted scenes
or not the other anime we considered no
I don't talk about it that still plays
out like it never left the 90s where the
bad boys ride motorcycles the black
people die first and everyone is really
into X Games alt storage lo Alita
uncanny valley girl
small wonder buzz I think that was a
typo what that was supposed to be
uncanny valley girl right yeah yeah if
you'll notice John says uncanny valley
girl oh and it's because I believe there
was a typo in the script and we just
flew right through it Wow
he will pronounce it exactly girl that's
our fault the typo shouldn't have been
there and I was watching the cut I'm
like I think he read the typo on
accident I'm Ron Bennett not his mistake
by our mistakes not his mistake
small wonder I like I like the thoughts
constantly that's been a real bug
Warhammer 40k as father of the eyed
Peter Park war meat boy my wife
and I think that was supposed to be my
wife okay but whose wife is it anyway I
did we know it yes yeah I like her Gwen
Stefani biblical they like everybody
we'll get the mark of the beast the
apocalypse I think that's what it is
just like like a stick-on jewel cuz he
takes it off he's like we said I think
he cut his off yeah he's like that's why
I removed my mark of zalem he doesn't
work always trying to I skied uphill
actual mortal engines actually does not
actually said any of these scenes I
understand he's just really really dusty
[Music]
yeah someone's surface area to get yeah
dusty with their big Gollum eyes so
let's dive into some viewer mail it says
I think it's as faithful as a big-budget
Hollywood adaptation of a manga can be
and for that alone I love it the only
real flaws in the movie are pretty much
the same flaws the manga has pretty much
everything with you go which I assume is
Hugo yes and who the f expected a
conclusion well this table did I mean
some when I go to a movie I do expect an
ending who expects stories to end this
is like where the philosophical divide
is for stuff like this because I feel
like some people go in and they're just
like I just want to see the things that
I know and like they're like solid film
which is okay but you have to be okay
also with people that don't like movies
because they don't have the things that
they like and like there's not an
objective set of things that should be
in a movie that are objective the
correct that's a white and you answer it
here and you can melt them down and spin
them in a sense I'm totally fine
that went to see Lolita and saw that
like Elina and saw the stuff and like
that they things that they brought from
that from the manga and that don't care
that because they know how the story
goes if they don't care they're not as
much of into the story as I am but like
that's cool I'm totally fine with them
not liking it but like you also have to
be okay brightness dealing it up in
their statement there is no conclusion
because they say who expected 111 rights
Adrien Jo Rose protozoa rights Jarrett's
got a lot of people wrote a best
adaptation of a manga edge of tomorrow
which I blame I blame that they changed
the name of it 17 was the movie based on
the original manga was it based on the
wasn't there a different separate like
book I don't know is it kill the killer
is that a different one that's different
it's all you need is kill and then they
called it live die repeat for a while
but all you need is kill is the original
my excuses they kept changing it but
that but fair point but yeah it's a
great movie I think we just forgot
tomorrow is better than this one yeah
which we've never done before
explain it to you later
okay let's see people saying they're in
love with Oliva cool
we know yeah I loved the movie then it's
two endings happen and I was like WTF
let's see I never read the cop I
genuinely loved the movie says mafia cat
88 points for getting someone with no
prior knowledge to really like it okay
that's good that's fine yeah that's
quite I do you want it I'll check out
the comics especially after that space
karate stuff it's not called Alita
battle angel it's called Gundam not
Gundam I things called GU MN is the name
of the manga that this is adapted from
that means something in Japanese yeah I
don't know I'm sure it does see this
every time you AI just hear the
collective voice of the internet
screaming the answer it's like they're
looking up and whispering whatever the
answer is so I'm just gonna have to deal
with I'm assuming this
I'll cry out cringe a couple other
things little off-topic
Timothy Farrelly writes I love honest
trailers but you got something wrong
Final Fantasy 10 is an RPG minigame
wrapped around blitzball Paul woods okay
it was fine okay I have played that game
and I found blitzball to be the least
satisfying I wanted to get back to my
amazing adventures with my team I want
to go back to was it snowboarding that's
my jam and I like that a card game I
think it's in 98 or 9 where it's like
you have the like four numbers and the
little top left you have to like put the
numbers in that's some of those
different let's see JD writes
live-action adaptations always suck wise
animation so taboo in Hollywood it's
just expensive it's they're not gonna
spend a hundred million dollars on an
animated thinks I spend a hundred
million dollars on a lot of animated
films they won't spend hundred dollars
on an animated film that's not for kids
can we know reliably that if you make
like an animated musical from Disney the
parents and families will go see it we
do not know reliably that if you make an
expensive movie for adults yes
that's animated that they will go see
yeah I also think there's a reason why
there's just different artistic mediums
like some stuff's just not gonna does
movie good like the Indiana Jones ripoff
video game uncharted I don't need I
don't need an uncharted movie because
the Uncharted games is a movie where
every now and then you're expected to
hit a button so he can hop yeah it's
really adding much I doesn't need
necessarily be a movie it works well it
was a movie and it was animated and it
was good and so just watch that one some
other things people apparently were
really excited about the Joe Joe pitch I
haven't seen JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
Joe 1 Joe what do you think about Joe
Joe would it work no Joe Joe stars
the day I found out about this anime was
my I'm mr. sparkle moment my Homer
Simpson like what this is our adventure
know their names his name is joe joestar
name is Joe Starr oh my god I thought
that Joe's name was like okay I thought
it was like a working name and he had
chosen it based off of his favorite
there's also the french rapper joey star
yeah wow you're climbing the ranks
that's why in any video we do someone's
someone says is that a Joe Joe reference
because my name is their name - hmm John
Jacob Jingleheimer Schmidt yeah it's a
really weird anime but that would also
not work okay well you couldn't yeah
you'd have to pick one timeline I feel
like yeah otherwise a lot of music ass
cuz I'm very ignorant on this I saw many
people were very happy to see this
reference it's a mean it's kind of a
meme okay I saw one person that said
that because we had called out JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure that we are blocked
and subscribed from is is there a oh did
they just hate it or is there a an anti
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
I'm a it's the internet so there was
just a person I really had a bone to
pick I mean you know Johnny Cash said if
the meme comes around at some point so I
[Laughter]
so I enjoyed I wanna threaten him bus
but there was a different anime you
chose at first the initial I know I'm
proud that I got it at least almost on
the page originally that it was good at
the tag was gonna be that we wish James
Cameron had discovered Yuri on ice which
is a delightful delightful anime about
male figures like the idea of James
Cameron making that yeah and it and the
show was gonna end with a bunch of boy
looking men ya know it's delightful but
I think Jojo is the more recognizable
big like big pop yeah yeah meant you
know that it's the cheap pop it's the
Mick Foley aren't we glad to be here in
insert city here and everyone's like
that's where I live that's where we are
right now okay well good choice good
choice that's all I want to talk about
that people were saying any final
thoughts on I know Robert Rodriguez can
write a really smart well-crafted script
like the expositions all right he paired
it down from 600 pages but like you know
like desperado has such smart exposition
with like people fearfully explaining
who this guy is that doesn't just get
across exposition but also like builds
to the mystique and the character and
the legend of the Mariachi and and stuff
like that and yeah this this movie just
feels like a committee wrote it real
quick to like hit the bingo of things
that the hordes of elite of fans that
were definitely gonna come out in droves
and make endgame money with this he's
just doing like the FAQ the FAQ sheet
that comes at the beginning all the
questions I'll sprinkle that throughout
the script believable Lita it's like a
primer or primer however you want to say
it for Aleta a cracker than a movie a
crane yeah well there you go I think it
does feel like part one of three and we
might get some more this did really well
overseas not so well here at home
borderline borderline so like it's on
the boil I'm a if they want to keep good
relations with camera and they'll keep
making them you know who knows yeah it's
it literally is like it made like just
enough worldwide that it's like yeah
like Pacific Rim territory exactly we'll
find out like three years from now if
they've crunched the numbers a
difference being I don't think they have
the Pacific grab option to like strip it
down right for say that she grew up if
they do it all like one contained space
karate dojo on the moon
maybe zalem is just one big warehouse
yeah fight your way yeah using all
styles of space karana your student
watch a movie honestly I think I've just
come up with your Aleta to Fitch guys
it's just the raid in space yeah well
sorry if I seem a little out of it my
head is on next week's honest trailer
and it's a it's a doozy this might be
the end of us so please come back next
week we'll be talking even more about
even more honest trailers thanks for
watching bye bye
[Music]
you